bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce tout nouveau webinaire
aujourd'hui consacré à la suite de ce
que nous avons commencé déjà sur les
deux séances précédentes donc on va
continuer sur nos données longitudinales
à travers l'exemple des trajectoires de
soins
donc pour rappel 1 la semaine dernière
nous avions fait une série d' analyse de
survie nous avions regardé
du coup la courbe de survie en tout cas
le temps entre le diagnostic et l'entrée
en soins le diagnostic et l'initiation
du traitement et le diagnostic et le
contrôle de l'infection
puis dans un deuxième temps nous avions
vu le temps entre l'entrée le diagnostic
l'entrée en soins puis parmi ceux qui
étaient entrés en soins entre l'entrée
en soins et l'initiation du traitement
puis parmi ceux qui avaient initié un
traitement entre l'initiation du
traitement et le contrôle de l'infection
par contre vous voyez que quand on a
fait cette analyse de survie classique
on a du coup été limitée par le fait que
du coup on ne regarder que la première
entrée en soins ou première initiation
de traitement au premier contrôle de
l'infection qu'on pouvait pas prendre du
coup en compte dans cette analyse là bas
des transitions descendante est sorti de
son par exemple ou des arrêts de
traitement ou des parcours plus complexe
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui nous allons
aborder
du coup une analyse de séquences qui va
être une manière d'aborder notre jeu de
données d'une autre sous un autre angle
alors je
pause que l'on repasse sur l'écran de
leur studio là j'ai réouvert le projet
tel qu'il était la semaine dernière une
toute petite remarque avant de continuer
ou si vous vous souvenez à un moment
donné nous avions fait une petite
fonction kkm qui permet de calculer
rapidement un kaplan meier
il y avait ici une toute petite toute
petite erreur de code puisqu'en fait
vous aviez vous aviez en fait simplement
ceux ci qui était le code qu'on avait la
fin de la séance la semaine dernière est
en fait en refaisant l'ensemble du
scripps à poser un problème parce que du
coup on appeler ici le fichier l'objet
tmp qui n'avait pas encore été créé donc
j'ai fait une petite correction dans le
code qui étaient déposés sur le site des
webinaires je vais d'abord copier un
dedans tmp puis du coup je vais faire
une transformation sur tmp donc ça
c'était un un tout petit point de détail
une autre possibilité serait était à à
cette étape-ci 1-2 thème est ici mais de
mettre un but puisque on part du fichier
1 ont fait une correction sur le fichier
1 et on sauvegarde sa dent et m donc
c'était une petite correction qui est
importante à avoir en tête dans tous les
cas sachez que si vous retournez sur le
site des webinaires je vous rappelle
l'ars marange points qui cube principaux
slash webinaire si vous avez sous
l'onglet séance vous retrouvez toutes
les séances et si vous allez sur la
séance du coup trajectoire de soin d'eux
vous allez pouvoir retrouver pour le
webinaire numéro 18 directement tous les
fichiers et donc le fichier et remarques
down corrigé alors pour la pour le
fichier d'aujourd'hui aiment l'idée
c'est que je poursuis mon analyse
donc je vais repartir
de 2,2 mon fichier qui s'appelle
trajectoire 0,2 point rmd est ce que je
vais faire je vais enregistrer sous
pour en faire une copie que je vais
appeler trajectoire v 0 3 point rm des
je vais changer la date donc aujourd'hui
nous sommes le 10 juin
est ce que je vais faire pour me
remettre dans l'état où j'étais à la
fringue l'analyse je vais relancer tout
le secret tous les scripts qui sont
actuellement présents et donc pour ça
tout simplement session est reine
wen au chase puisqu'on aura fischer md
et en faisant cette opération là ça va
me permettre de ré exécuté l'ensemble du
code
les présents ont envoyé on voit là
l'avancée progressive et l'avancée
global ici et ça va me permettre de
pouvoir me remettre à la fin de mon slip
dans l'état dans lequel je suis censé
trouver l'ensemble de mes données à
cette étape là on va
quelques secondes que le script
s'exécute forcément un plus le script
est long et plus il ya des éléments plus
plus ça peut prendre de temps mais c'est
une bonne manière de repartir de l'étape
précédente et d'être certain qu'on a
bien en mémoire le bon état des
différentes données
alors je vais me positionner à la toute
fin de mon script vous avez d'ailleurs
ici oui les graphiques nous avions fait
dernière fois puisque nous avions aussi
refait les graphiques par sexe et je
vais maintenant faire une nouvelle
partie est donc aujourd'hui on va tout
d'abord commencé par une analyse de
séquences sur l'ensemble du fichier
donc je
rappel on avait abordé dans un webinaire
précédent l'analyse de séquences
l'analyse de ces commence consiste à
recréer pour chaque individu
sa trajectoire sous la forme d'une série
d'étapes attend donc là ça va être le
statut dont les sons mois par mois et
ensuite on va pouvoir regarder la
distance qui est entre différentes
séquences pour voir s'il ya des
typologies de trajectoire qui est en
train d'émerger
le plus simple quand on veut faire une
analyse de séquences ca d'avoir les
données dans un format large
c'est-à-dire une ligne par individu et
une colonne pour chaque pas de temps or
si on regarde actuellement l'état de nos
données donc votre objet c'est caire
trajectory zh et je vous le représente
que vous l'ayez en mémoire quatre fois
j'ai autorise c'est un format long on a
une ligne par individu et par pat temps
j'en profite pour rappeler que nous
avons la variable idées qui nous permet
d'identifier les individus variable
marne qui contient le la situation mois
par - et enfin la variable vnt tout ce
qui est donc le statut dont les soins
qui va être notre savaria d'intérêt et
si je regarde avec un petit look fort
comment sont codées mes différentes
variables pour kirstetter c'est une
variable textuel labellisé avec des le
statut diagnostiqués mais pas suivi
c'est le statut suivi mais pas dans les
soins mais pas ce traitement pardon tu
es sous traitement mais pas contrôler et
est sous traitement et contrôlé avec une
charge virale supprimer double valeur de
s
donc ce que j'aimerais faire un c1 c'est
un tableau de données qui va être large
donc je vais repartir
je vais créer
objet que j'ai appelé large je pars de
care trajectory zh à cette étape là je
vais garder uniquement
[Musique]
donc je vais garder comme variable idée
membres et kirstetter pour une raison
pratique vous allez voir pourquoi je
vais en profiter pour à la volée
renommée marne ont simplement m
donc pour rappel si je fais juste qui
après lecture vise elect idée un jeu
obtient un tableau qui contient juste
les trois variables y des monstres
nommés en m&a states pour passer d'un
format long un format large
on va utiliser les fonctions de taille
lierre qui font parties de tailles
diverses et notamment la fonction qui
votent wider pour rappel vous avez payé
votre langue heures quand on veut passer
d'un format large d'un format non et
pivote wider quand on est passé d'un
format long un format large si on a un
doute sur les paramètres depuis votre
haider eh bien on va regarder simplement
l'aide de la fonction on n'a pas besoin
de connaître par coeur toutes les
fonctions qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin à un
moment donné et donc du coup qu'est ce
qui va être intéressant ça vient
d'indiquer names femmes
donc l'idée c'est que chacune des lignes
pour un même individu vont être
utilisées vont être utilisés hamon pour
nommer nono variable et veilleuse femme
a pour ce peuple et le contenu nicolon
donc ici je vais fermer ma femme aime
marathon des le plus simple j'ai même
plus besoin de renommée en m
donc femmes membres vous et moi j'avais
et value femme kate moss alors voyons
obtiens si je fais ceci voyons voir
l'objet que j'obtiens déjà la variable
idées qui étaient présentes
rectifiez d'accord j'ai des nouvelles
variables qui sont nommés à partir de
membres avec une valeur qui est prise
dans christophe et si jamais amende et
j'avais des mois qu'ils n'étaient pas
présents par exemple individus 9 n'avait
pas de valeur pour la pour le mois 3
simplement j'ai dna qui sont rajoutés
alors mes colocs s'appelle du coup 0 1 2
3 4 5 c'est pas forcément ça serait un
petit peu mieux d'avoir quelque chose
qui commence par une lettre et je peux
rajouter vous l'avez ici vous avez nîmes
ce préfixe on peut donner un préfixe au
nom des variables et donc ici je vais
indiquer n'aime ce préfixe égal m
et si je fais ça hein hein mais
variables sont maintenant nommé f0 m1 m2
m3 m4 m6 et c'est maintenant
j'ai mon objet large que j'ai ce tableau
là on va pouvoir préparer notre objet
séquence pour rappel l'analyse de
séquences se fait avec le package
traminer donc il faut le charger mais
moi si je veux éviter d'avoir tous les
messages au chargement d'un package
construit mon rapport je peux rajouter
quietly égal ou c'est juste que sa
charge de manière silencieuse
le package et non pour rappel la
fonction qui permet à de fer qui permet
de faire un objet de séquencer la
fonction secte s est donc je vais faire
une petite séquence avec tout de mes
observations je vais l'appeler sec
underscore hall ce qu'on verra tout à
l'heure on refera une autre à nice de
séquences sur un sous-échantillon est
alors à 15
aussi de poser des questions par message
dans le chatt youtube oui oui vous
pouvez poser des questions sur votre
chatte youtube à intervalles réguliers
j'essaye d'aller les voir et de répondre
donc je reviens à la création du nombre
d'objets de séquences ans donc j'ai mon
objet là je vais prendre donc la
fonction c'est sec dès ce
encore une fois on n'est pas obligé par
coeur tous les paramètres on peut
charger let de cette fonction on peut
dans pour pouvoir les différents
paramètres qui sont possibles ce qui
nous faut impérativement c'est le jeu de
données
donc on se donne et c'est celui que je
viens de créer sauf que la variable idée
si je vous remonte le jeu de données
large
j'ai une variable identifiant puis j'ai
tout mais variable de moi donc en fait
les données qui servent à la séquence
c'est tout les colonnes sauf la colonie
d donc je vais faire un select - idées
et on va d
à commencer uniquement avec ça alors
qu'est-ce que j'ai il m'a créé un objet
de séquences il m'a dit qu'on a trouvé
des valeurs manquantes
il a identifié de 1929 séquence on a
fait deux mille neuf cent individus à
il a détecté automatiquement un alphabet
parce que qu'ils étaient donc cdst et il
m'a créé mon premier objet directement
ceci étant dit on va essayer d'améliorer
un tout petit peu notre objet de
séquences en rajoutant quelques
informations complémentaires par exemple
voyez nous avons un paramètre à idées
qui est optionnelle mais qui permet de
donner le nom de la colonne qui
contiendrait un identifiant la du cou
ainsi amandine vais avoir un changement
dans l'ordre où les avions devaient être
amenés à trier nos le donnait en fait
l'ordre des lignes serait plus forcément
le même donc du coup il peut être lié en
général tout recommandé de garder un
identifiant dont le fichier séquence
concret donc là c'est large idée donc en
fait je passe le vecteur à 15
identifiant l'alphabet il la trouvait
tout seul donc mais je peux
éventuellement 8 préciser si je veux
être sûr que la femme est dans un
certain ordre
donc là pour le coup je vous remonte
inquiète retour jacques tord is un
casse-tête voire faire le bouc fort il y
6 2
notre arrivée on aimerait qu'ils sont
dans l'ordre des cts pas ce ski c'est ce
qui fait sens or là il actuellement
codées dans l'ordre cdft donc je vais
préciser qu'on assabeh doit être
normalement dans l'ordre dès ctf alors
l'ordre il a pas forcément un gros
impact dans la suite mais ça la plupart
des représentations graphiques du cou
tienne compte de l'ordre que l'on a
donné donc c'est un petit peu mieux
et puis je vais donner quand même un nom
un peu un peu court mais qui donnait
quand même quelque chose qui sont un peu
plus explicite que lorsque l'on pourra
faire des sorties graphiques et donc
vous avez la fonction states on qui
permet de donner du coup une étiquette
et donc j'espère quelque chose de simple
un diagnostic est resté en soins sous
traitement et contrôle et n'oubliez pas
avoir lancé d'agnostiques et met pas en
soins ont soin mais pas sous traitement
sous traitement mais pas contrôler et la
dernière ces diagnostics et en soins
sous traitement et contrôle et d'ajouter
des noms courts l'intérêt de faire ceci
c'est
ça nous a mis quelques quelques
étiquettes et puis je peux en profiter
du coup pour voir mon résultat vais
faire juste le retrouver en fait la
cascade de soins qui se fait directement
avec sac des pelotes de mon objet
séquence hall et voyez là vous avez le
graphique que l'on obtient alors deux
petites choses qu'on peut faire pour
améliorer un voyez parfois la légende a
du mal à s'afficher un souvent avec avec
les fonctions de deux traminer mais il
ya un petit paramètres qui s'appelle les
djeuns un point pop qui permet
normalement dans les graves dans les
fonctions graphiques de 2,2 traminer de
changer en fait la taille du texte dans
la légende
et si le fait ceci j'ai mis les devants
tôt 2.25 samassa dit je veux réduire la
taille du texte
et puis après on va se faire changer ce
paramètre là mais voyez j'ai une légende
qui du coup un peu plus visible
ce qui serait intéressant ça serait
quand même de pouvoir retrouver le code
couleur qu'on avait utilisé dans nos
graphiques jusqu'à présent si je vous
rappelle ce qu'on avait fait alors
c'était il ya déjà deux séances vous
souvenez ces graphiques là qu'on est au
tout début en première séance au nos
trajectoires de soins qui était jaune
vert bleu violet foncé
parce qu'on avait utilisé une palette de
couleurs particulières qui était la
palette de couleurs viridis et qu'on
avait appelé ici avec ce qu'ils firent
veridis quand on crée un objet de
séquences il est possible de passer une
palette de couleurs c'est la fonction
c'est sait pas alors il en led
on peut en fait fournir une série de
couleurs de une palette de couleurs est
donc j'ai personnalisé des couleurs
alors je peux pas faire appel à inscrire
au fil des oui dis ça c'est quand on
fait du gg pelote mais il se trouve que
le pack est véridique fournit aussi une
fonction s'appelle viridis tout
simplement et si je donne un nom par
exemple 4 ça me renvoie la palette de
quatre couleurs voyez avec les codes
hexadécimaux à des couleurs
correspondante
donc je peux dire ici viridis 4 qui
correspond du cou à cette série de
couleurs et ça me permet du coup
d'indiquer les codes couleurs à utiliser
les voyons voir le graphique de obtient
alors si vous regardez le petit souci
c'est que dans les premiers graphique
qu'on avait fait on a utilisé ce jaune
pour les personnes diagnostiquées et
c'était de plus en plus foncé au fur et
à mesure qu'on ait des vers le contrôle
et la la planète elle est inversé si je
regarde la date de la fonction viridis
donc à la c voici la lettre de la
fonction viridis d'accord vous voyez
qu'il ya parmi eux s'appelle direction
ici et donc direction ça permet qui vaut
un home voisin il venait d'indiquer
l'ordre des couleurs dans l'échelle et
donc si je rajoute ici direction égale
moisins javert simplement l'ordre des
couleurs mais du coup je retrouve bien
ce qui nous intéresse est là
et poser dans le chat qui est comment
interpréter ce graphique alors je vais
je aller vite que ça c'est un graphique
qu'on avait déjà vue dont dans le
chapitre dédié à l'analyse de séquences
mais ce graphique 1 le sec 10 pelote ces
trafics de distribution ça nous indique
en fait la distribution de chacun des
statuts à chaque pas de temps autrement
dit ici à n 01 on voit que kassie la
totalité 98% des statuts documenté am 0
c'est le statut diagnostiqué il ya 1 ou
2 % de l'échantillon qui sont dans
statut en soins voire même sous
traitement et ça ça correspond dans
d'autres jeux de données a fait avec des
personnes qui ont été dépistés
directement dans une clinique et le jour
même en fait on les a on les a mis sous
traitement
et là vous allez en fait du coût pour
chaque pas tendre c'est la distribution
des statuts un pas de temps en ayant
retiré les valeurs manquantes
je voulais dit on n'a pas le même nombre
de personnes si on en revient à la
première description des données qu'on
avait on avait les effectifs là vous
avez un le graphique avec les effectifs
un conte avait fait dans la toute
première séance
sur l'année ses trajectoires de soins
donc c'est exactement la même chose sauf
que là on est en effectif et non pas en
pourcentage et voyez que au fur et à
mesure du temps on a de moins en moins
de monde un donc si on some ça à 100 %
qu'on avait fait la dernière fois qui
était celui ci est bien en fait voilà au
fur et à mesure on mesure les choses sur
de moins en moins de personnes et
d'ailleurs le graphique qu'on avait fait
là à la toute première saison sur la
trajectoire de soins correspond
exactement à ce graphique si la
différence est que dans le celui qu'on a
vu juste avant on avait inversé dans
quel ordre on mettait on empilait les
différentes valeurs et puis notre
graphique on l'avait coupé à 36 mois
alors que là il va bien jusqu'au bout
des données qui sont collectés
maintenant qu'on a fait à notre
graphique ce qu'on va calculer on veut
calculer c'est du coup et c'est de voir
est ce qu'il ya des typologies qui
émerge donc je vous rappelle le principe
c'est que on va calculer une distance
entre les différentes séquences cette
distance qu'on va calculer par optimhome
matching va permettre du coup d'avoir
une matrice distance entre les individus
et à partir de cette matrice deux
distances on va pouvoir faire une
classification ascendante hiérarchique
donc ça ça avait déjà été abordé dans le
webinaire dédié à la classification
ascendante hiérarchique ainsi que d'un
webinaire dédié à l'analyse de séquences
qu'on avait vu dans le webinaire sur
l'analyse de cinq ans c'était le cas le
plus courant en matière de petits mots
le matching c'est à dire on avait vu un
tea party un sous-ensemble particulier
de l'optimal matching qui était ce qu'on
appelle la méthode lcs le lendemain
gosse common cette séquence la méthode
sur la la sous- séquences comme une des
plus longues en fait ça revient à
considérer que pour passer d'une
séquence à une autre on va compter le
nombre de changements qui est requis je
veux vous refait la une petite
explication un peu rapide du prince et
de l'autisme ou le matching supposons
j'ai une séquence qui soit a à bbb
d'accord et une autre séquence qui soit
a à b à b et b
qu'on voit c'est que dans ces deux
séquences là pour passer l'idée si on
regardait ce que je peux passer d'une
séquence à une autre en permutant ou
faisant des changements dans quelques
unes des coûts pour passer la séquence
une la séquence 2 ici il suffit de
changer à ambès en général la règle de
badens et on considère qu'un coup de
substitution c'est remplacer à par b ça
revient ça coûte 2 c'est le le coût par
défaut pourquoi parce qu on envisage
deux types de coups le coup de
substitution là c'est un statut par un
autre et les coûts hind el d'ajouts du
pression est donc dans la version la
plus classique
on va faire des cours intel 2 1 et déco
substitution de deux parce qu'une autre
manière pour passer de aa à bbb
c'est de dire je supprime à ça me coûte
je rajoute b ça me coûte 1 c'est pour ça
que le coût de substituer le coup une
d'elles un supprimé en fait on sait
partir du principe que remplacer un
statut par un autre ça veut dire en
supprimer un peu rajouté un c'est pour
ça que par défaut dans la version la
plus classique
on est sur un coup de substitution de 2
et un coude ajout suppression de 1,6 par
contre ma deuxième séquence était a à
bbb à la pour passer de celle ci est
celle ci il faut que je rentre en somme
un as en b ça me coûte 2 puis que je
rajoute un à +1 et là j'aurai un coût de
3 et pour rappel la distance qu'on a
entre deux séquences et finalement le
les coûts en fait combien qui et combien
nous faut faire de transformation sur ma
séquence pour passer de l'une à l'autre
alors bien
sûr il ya des fois je pourrais dire je
rentre on pourrait avoir des coûts qui
sont bien plus supérieur supposons que
nous ayons dans certains cas en fait on
peut avoir plusieurs manières de passer
de l'une à l'autre un et l'algorithme de
petits moules machi calcul galles le
coût minimum pour passer d'une séquence
à l'autre et c'est ça qui nous intéresse
ceci étant dit nous sommes dans sa cage
un petit peu particulier parce que quand
on suppose que tous les coups de
discussion sur équivalent à on part du
principe que ça coûte la même chose de
passer d'un certain sature un autre
statut
si je reviens dans mon cas présent on
avait vu que nos différents statuts sont
hiérarchisées on est des rhinos tickets
plus on rentre en soins puis on passe au
traitement puis on devient contrôler et
donc d'une certaine manière je peux me
dire que passer du statut diagnostiqués
au statut contrôler ça coûte plus que de
passer simplement de diagnostiquer en
soins parce qu'en fait pour passer du
statut des diagnostics et au stade fiu
contrôler dans le cas présent il faut
être entré en soins et avoir initié un
traitement puis avoir achevé le contrôle
biologique
là on est vraiment un cas particulier
nos statuts sont vraiment erard cheese
et les uns par rapport aux autres
donc quand vous avez pas de statut
hérarchie c est qu on ne savait pas
prenez vraiment les coûts par défaut
c'est-à-dire un coup de substitution de
2 et un coup d'ajouts suppression une
d'elles 2 1
mais lorsque vous avez une meilleure
connaissance de vos données on peut
faire des hypothèses plus précis on peut
éventuellement faire le petit bol
matching on navigue en soi même une
matrice de coûts alors pour créer une
matrice du coup on peut passer par la
fonction sec cost si je regarde l'aide
de cette fonction
la fonction
cette cost permet de réaliser des
matrices de coups il ya d'ailleurs
plusieurs méthodes qui sont utilisées
constante qui est on a le même coup pour
tout les substitutions on atterrit reds
qui permet de faire des maîtres les yeux
coûts basée sur les taux de transition
servait au sur la distance de google à
un moment donné
n'hésitez pas à m'en allais vraiment
regarder le manuel du package traminer
parce qu'il est très très bien fait et
vous avez toutes les explications sur
les enjeux théoriques et méthodologiques
c'est de ces différentes approches nous
ici on va faire une matrice de coups de
substitution qui est basée sur notre
théorisation on part du principe que
nous avons 3 et adam processus qui sont
rentrés en soins qu'à initier un
traitement est atteint le niveau
biologique et donc du coup informatrice
du coup ils rares cheese et pour ça je
vais tout d'abord créer une matrice de
coûts avec sakho est d'accord alors à sa
cause on va d'abord lui passer un objet
de séquences ici nous ils s'appellent
sec haut et on va lui passer une méthode
est là on va partir déjà de maîtrise de
coûts constante donc ça va
une matrice de coups d'accords avec une
valeur constante et si je regarde
l'objet cookies et créer en fait voyez
c'est l'objectif c'est une liste avec
deux informations d'une pas un premier
objet intel qui est la valeur d'âge aux
suppressions et un 2e objet qui une
matrice qui indique les coûts de
substitution d'un statut vers un autre
et plus spécifiquement ça dit que pour
passer de diagnostic et adiaké ça change
ça coûte rien et passer de diagnostiquer
à en soins il ya un coût de 1
ce que je vais faire maintenant j'ai
modifier manuellement mon objet mon
objet coup donc des gens à s'intéresser
au coût de substitution donc c'est
l'objet coup sm d'accord donc ça c'est
une matrice donc une matrice ça peut
être vu comme un élément à deux entrées
et je vous occuper de la première ligne
donc indiquer un pour dire que je veux
toucher à la première ligne virgule et
rien derrière pour dire je toutes les
colonnes de cette première ligne et je
vais indiquer une nouvelle série de
valeurs et là je le fais vraiment
manuellement
donc je pars du principe que de passer
de diagnostiquer adamczyk et ce ne coûte
rien c'est normal à des gones à l'est
toujours sur 0 ça va me coûter 1 pour
entrer en soins ça me coûte 2 pour
passer de diagnostiquer à sous
traitement parce que je considère que
j'ai deux étapes et ça va me coûter 3
pour passer de diagnostic et à contrôler
puisque j'ai eu trois étapes ci
cusin et regardez maintenant à quoi
ressemble l'objet coup j'ai modifié ma
première ligne alors j'ai pris ces
d'écriture là parce que c'est un peu
plus facile de faire ligne à ligne
plutôt que de décrire le code pour
toutes les lignes
maintenant si je m'intéresse à ma
deuxième ligne donc là je pars de en
soins pour sortir de soins c'est-à-dire
le coût que ça me prend pour sortir de
son oncle était en soins je repasse en
diagnostic je recule d'une case deux ans
soit en soins ça vaut toujours 02 en
soins sous traitement j'ai avancé d'une
case et de 11 points à contrôler j'ai
avancé de deux cases maintenant
ce qui se passe lorsque je pars de sous
traitement et bien si j'avais deux sous
traitement a diagnostiqué j'ai reculé de
2 codes de deux cases donc j'ai parcouru
une distance de 2 si je vais de sous
traitement à ans - j'ai reculé case si
je reste au même endroit je n'ai pas
bougé
et sinon j'avance d'une case enfin si je
pars de contrôler et bien contrôlé a
diagnostiqué j'ai récusée trois cases
contrôlé à en soins j'ai reculé de deux
cases contrôlé à sous traitement j'ai
reculé de gaz
et oui alors quand je lis reculer ou
avancer un seuil pour une magnon imagine
mais toutes les valeurs sont bien
positive
il n'y a pas de valeur négative puisque
quand j'avance ou que je recule dans
notre intuition on parcourt toujours une
distance positive donc en faisant ça je
met à jour la matrice de coups et je
vous montre maintenant à quoi ressemble
objets coup j'ai mis à jour la partie
maintenant la question c'est qu'est-ce
que je prends comme valeur pour le coup
idem donc la valeur d'un jour
suppression l'idée c'est que une règle
simple à retenir prenez comme coup intel
donc ajout/suppression grosso modo la
moitié du coût maximum donc s'il fait
max coup sm
dilemme je recherchais maximum qui s'il
va être trois et je le divise par deux
pourquoi c'est que si jamais abandonné
on doit passer de diagnostiquer à en
soins en une d'elles ça me coûterait un
ennemi puissant ennemi ça me coûterait 3
faire une substitution coûterait que 1
l'algorithme va toujours prendre
l'élément qui va être le le
ce qui coûte le moins donc en fait les
queens d'elle ils vont surtout servir
pour des des séquences qui n'ont pas la
même longueur pour du court rajouter les
éléments qui sont manquants en fin de
séquence est atteinte du coup et
permettre de conques de comparer des
séquences de longueurs différentes
et donc je vous montre maintenant
l'objet comme amatrices du coût final
avec les coûts de substitution voyez ils
sont en fait tirard chizé mais j'ai des
hiérarchies zay parce que là j'ai un
cadre théorique 1 dans la manière dont
j'ai conçu que mon objet trajectoire de
son aimée statut et j'ai fait quelque
chose de simple fait un par étapes
parce que si on veut commencer à dire
que passer de diagnostic est en soin ça
vaut 0 5 mai devant son traitement coûte
un ennemi il faut avoir un quatrième
fort pour se dire qu'il ya des étapes
qui coûte plus cher que d'autres
donc ici est toujours d'être d'être un
peu de pas trop complexifie non plus les
éléments mais là du coup j'ai pouvoir
prendre en compte que des personnes qui
font directement des passages un certain
statut à un autre d'une d'un mois sur
l'autre
en fait ils ont avancé de plusieurs
cases et ça c'est important par rapport
à ce que je veux faire
maintenant j'ai une matrice des courants
je vais pouvoir calculer une matrice de
distance alors pour rappel le calcul
d'une matrice distance je vais appeler
distincts et puis j'ai gardé le hall 1
pour pour savoir que je vais partir de
cet all
il s'agit en fait d'appliquer la
fonction sec 10 tu as mon objet sec
hall qui va
angers en fait c'est remonte à 1 sec 10
a gardé l'aide de la fonction nous ce
qu'on avait lu la dernière fois pour le
paramètre méthode on avait utilisé
méthode égale lcs donc acs pour
longueuil chromosome 16 points ce qui
correspond en fait au cas particulier de
petits veaux le matching où tous les
coups de substitution sont égales à deux
et la main et le queens elle est égale 1
à 1 en fait c'était le le coup renvoyé à
cette étape là donc j'avais juste besoin
d'un déclic méthodes légales et c est ce
là ça a été un petit peu différent on va
on a une maîtrise des coûts personnalisé
dont je vais lui dire
om pour optimum matching c'est là la
version générique d'optymo imaging mais
dans ce cas là il va me falloir lui
passer un coup intel
comment ça c'est nécessaire lorsqu'on
utilise om
et puis passer la matrice du coup
sm de substitution donc du coup sm et
ben sékou dollars et celle qu'on a créé
juste avant et les queens d'elle ces
sujets définit ses coûts dollars in
dallas donc là j'avais calculé une
matrice de distance 1
elle a alors pourquoi chez qui
la femme il ya une erreur dans ses mains
art
j'ai une erreur dans la cemac dans les
wilayas 2 2 2 ici j'ai peut-être pas dû
faire tout ça on relance toute la partie
du code allait bien sm 1 2 3 1 1 1 2 1 0
1 3 2 1
qu'a donc là j'ai bien mis à jour et je
relance mon calcul on va voir si j'ai
encore ces messages là est donc là
ça se met en oeuvre et j'ai pas de
message d'erreur et donc il m'indique
même donc voyez c'est toujours important
de lire les messages qu arrive à l'écran
là sinon j'aurais eu des messages
d'erreur hélas le calcul s'est fait en 4
7 secondes
ça se fait relativement bien parce que
j'ai pas une matrice trop grande alors
un message de saïdou goro vous avez une
séquence de longues heures 120 et plus
de cent mille patients alors je peux
vous dire qu'elle capaci d'ordinateur il
vous faudra parce que c'est vrai que
c'est une très grosse matrice du coup il
ya deux aspects qui sont à prendre en
compte ça va être la question de la
mémoire ram merkel ont dit vous allez
manquer de mémoire ram pour calculer la
matrice de coups et puis le temps de
calcul
quand vous avez des des gros fichiers
comme ça il faut que vous fassiez le
test et puis faut parfois de patients
parfois pour lancer un calcul le soir et
attendre le lendemain matin pour voir si
s'exécuter je peux pas vous répondre
telle quelle la capacité exact qu'il
vous faudra donc il faut essayer et voir
les messages d'erreur que vous aurez si
jamais votre machine personnelle est
insuffisante pour faire ce calcul là
dans ce cas là il faut passer sur des
versions serveur de leur studio
alors maintenant
notre matrice du coup on va calculer
notre dans trop grave pour rappel un an
dro gramasa ce calcul directement avec h
clust donc je vais l'appeler arbres hall
je garde le suffixe au le pot bien
distinguer ce qu'on fera un peu plus
tard donc ch classe à laquelle on passe
la matrice de coûts à leurs petites
subtilités 1 mais vérifier simplement le
chapitre analyseur un autre matrice de
coups qu'on a calculé que ça existe il
faut juste parfois il a représenté sous
un format de classe 10
il suffit juste appliqué à ce disque sur
disque
aulas c'est juste pour la seule
actuellement si vous regardez d'ist au
lin hsin st
le matrix et si on lui fait as 10 ça
présente comme ça derrière c'est une
matrice de distance voilà et c'est
justin et hqe lost le va préférer ça et
puis la méthode la plus courante c'est
la méthode howard points et 2 et
voiliers
c'est fait assez vite si j'avais pas mis
le h10 le h10 pardon voyez il a un petit
problème parce qu'il détecte pas en fait
le bon format delà c'est le bon format
de la matrice vous faut voilà faut juste
la passer avec astuces pour bien
préciser c'est une matrice de distance
donc maintenant qu'on a une matrice de
distance on a à un arbre alors je peux
voir rapidement à quoi ressemble mon
entre nos mains avec un la version
rapide pas forcément la plus propre la
nation rapide s'est passé par klotz 1
donc on voit notre programme alors voyez
toutes les étiquettes qui traîne mais on
voit bien que là il ya un grand
découpage ici en haut
et puis d'autres découpage un peu plus
bas et puis surtout pour pouvoir bien
visualiser en fait notre d'ordre au
gramme mais aligné avec du coup un tapis
de séquences pour voir à quoi
correspondent les différentes sous
classe on avait une fonction bien
pratique qui s'appelle la fonction sec
est map c'est qu'être map qu'on peut
trouver du coup dans le package sec en
boucle historiquement elle était dans jl
utilisent mais vous n'êtes pas besoin de
gilles tease du coup aujourd'hui pour ça
donc la borie sec mbook si je fais du
coup sec et map
on doit d'abord lui passé l'objet de
séquences donc cette hall puis un temps
programme qui est de coûts arbres
graphique là alors je vais jouer un
petit peu à l'écran donc je vais je
voudrais le voir dans une plus grande
fenêtre il ya ce petit bouton
ici on pour voir le graphique dans une
plus grande fenêtre alors voyez on s'est
un petit peu pixelisé si j'avais voulu
j'aurais pu éventuellement décider
d'augmenter la taille de la figure par
exemple en disant que j'avais une figure
qui fasse le bit sur 8 pouces on peut
changer du coup facilement vu comme nous
un document markdown le ratio hauteur
largeur et la taille de la figure
produite
donc là on la voit un petit peu
différemment ce qu'on voit donc ça
reprend les codes couleurs qu'on ait dit
non j'ai deux séquences ce qui apparaît
surtout quand on regarde ce sedan trop g
c'est qu'on a il est des catégories 6 a
cédé des séquences qui sont longues et
puis des séquences qui sont courtes 1 et
donc on voit en fait qu'une partisans
gros g
outre les statuts qui vont participer
effectivement du regroupement des
séquences il ya quand même une très
forte tendance à regrouper ensemble des
séquences qui sont longues et des
séquences qui sont courtes tout à fait
normal parce que quand on calcule une
distance entre deux séquences et bien
une distance courte qu'il n'y a que
quelques statues et une distance long
qui en a beaucoup
du coup il faut rajouter les statuts à
la fin on a un kouign dell qui
s'applique à chaque fois qu'on rajoute
des statuts pour atteindre la longueur
et donc du coût des séquences qui sont
longues sont fortes monde distante de
séquences qui sont courtes
la question
se pose c'est est-ce que la longueur de
la séquence est inhérente au phénomène
j'observe
ou bien est-ce que la longueur de la
séquence est plutôt propre à ma manière
d'observer des choses dans un certain
nombre de cas où vous pourriez avoir des
séquences qu'ils sont définis par un
événement origin est un événement de sa
propre aux phénomènes étudiés et auquel
cas la longueur de la séquence
correspond à une partie intégrante du
phénomène que l'on étudie dans notre cas
de figure assez juste qu'on a eu des
gens qui ont été recrutés à un moment
différent dans notre observatoire et
puis simplement d'autres observations
bah oui on arrête l'enquète et donc du
coup la durée d'observation est plutôt
un effet il y à notre dispositif d'
enquête et non phénomène et du coup ce
que j'aimerais voir c'est ce qu'il ya
des profils de trajectoire qui émergent
n'est pas qu'ils soient différencier par
rapport à la longueur de la séquence
mais par rapport à ce qui compose la
séquence et donc du coup ici ce qui
serait intéressant ça serait plutôt va
de comparer uniquement sur le contenu de
la séquence est une technique pour ça va
consister à comparer uniquement des
séquences de même longueur donc le
principe on va revenir notre premier
graphique qui nous montrait le nombre
d'observations qu'on avait pas moins est
visible ici
d'accord donc la celle
non des individus qu'on va voir par moi
ce que je vais faire j'ai pris une
période de temps puis je vais analyser
la trajectoire au cours de cette période
de temps mais uniquement parmi les gens
qui étaient observés au moins cette dure
elle a alors je pourrais être intéressé
me dire mais je prends que des périodes
de trois ans parce que c'est intéressant
d'avoir du temps long et j'ai observé
que les gens que j'observais au moins 36
mois mais si je prends les gens que
j'observais au moins trente six mois
j'en ai que 190 je perds énormément
d'intérêt l'observation
je pourrais dire je vais prendre les
gens que j'observais que six mois là
j'en ai 2444 j'ai plein d'observation
différentes mais en même temps si moi
j'ai finalement qu'une petite période et
je perds un peu l'intérêt de mon suivi
longitudinal qui est de savoir comment
le phénomène se déroule au cours du
temps ici ce qu'on va prendre pour la
suite je vous propose de prendre dix
huit 18 mois d'une part parce qu'on n'a
encore 1317 personne c'est surtout après
18 mois qui a tout d'un coup d'une chute
dans l'est dans les recrutements
et ça permet d'avoir un peu une sorte de
compromis entre assez durée
d'observation et en même temps et en
même temps un nombre d'individus
suffisant
donc j'ai retourné à la fin du document
contre le faim d'accord et je vais pas
aller plus avant sur ce
séquence mais on va partir sur une
deuxième analyse de séquences sur 18
mois donc 7
si on va refaire un fichier qui contient
que les individus qui sont observés au
moins 18 ans alors une manière un peu
rapide un d'avoir la la durée
d'observation on nous avons la fonction
5ème d'accord donc cinq labs permet
d'avoir le nombre de points dans une
séquence je vous l'avais dit en plus
cela n'a pas de trou de nos séquences
donc je vais prendre large qui contient
les données l'une paris on a déjà fait
un fichier large donc autant profiter et
je vais rajouter d'information qui est
la longueur des séquences que j'obtiens
avec la fonction sync chelem et je
calcule à partir d'un objet secte hall
alors là je récupère une information
d'objets sec hall pour l'appliquer
directement dans mon tableau large ça
fonctionne parce que c'est qu on avait
été construit à partir du tableau large
et qu' à aucun moment je n'ai changé
l'ordre des observations trouvé deux
objets du coup comme lors des
observations n'a jamais changé un jeu
y'a bien ça match bien on veut dire là
sinon j'aurais dû récupérer
l'information de manière un peu
différente et prendre 5 lens reprend les
identifiants et refaire un une fusion
avec un left john si jamais les hommes
n'étaient pas les mêmes pour être sûr
que j'associe bien une bonne valeur aux
bonnes observations
maintenant on va faire du coup un objet
large donc je vais appeler m18
donc je vais prendre l'objet large
sauf que j'avais retenir certaines
choses déjà ce que je veux c'est que les
individus qui sont arrivées jusqu'à m18
les individus ont été observées jusqu'à
m18
ils ont 19 points d'observation puisque
j'avais un point d'observation pour l0
donc ça me fait 2-0 m18 ça fait 19
points d'observation donc j'ai fait un
filter et je ne vais garder que les
lignes correspondant à des individus
observés au moins jusqu'à m18 dont qui
ont une
séquence deux longueurs 19 et dont j'ai
faire 5,9 supérieure ou égale à 10 9 par
ailleurs je vais regard qu les une
séquence mais en prenant uniquement en
compte les données collectées jusqu'à
m18 je veux pas prendre ce qu'il ya
derrière donc je vais comparer ces
individus uniquement sur leurs 18
premiers mois et donc du coup je vais
réduire mon tableau avec du coup cette
fois-ci select en prenant la variable
idée et puis les variables f0 à m18
donc je vous rappelle dans un select on
peut utiliser de dix plats hier on peut
utiliser cette tentation nom d'une
variable jusqu'à une variable ça me
permet du coup de créer un objet large
18 qui contient que les variables f0 am
maintenant je vais créer mon objet de
séquences alors comme je suis un peu
feignant
je vais aller récupérer ici le code
j'avais utilisé tout à l'heure je le
copie
je vais à la toute fin je le copier donc
là je vais faire un objet de jeu appelé
sec m18 qui par de larges et mme 18/100
l'identifiant la barbe identifiant j'ai
la place est ici
par contre c'est bien les mêmes alphabet
les mêmes d'état et je vais lâcher que
ça c'est bien construit correctement
alors lançons calcul si je regarde le
code ici tout s'est bien passé toutes
mes séquences ont une longueur minimum
de dix neuf maximum de 19 donc j'ai bien
le même nom d'observation pour chacun
deux points des deux mais point de temps
et j'ai ici
le graphique des distributions chacun
des états au cours du temps batta bicec
enfin c'est bien la distribution des
états maintenant on va refaire
l'analyse de séquences donc chez
calculatrice à distance
donc je vous rappelle le code qu'on
avait utilisé juste avant il est l'un je
vais reprendre
carrément tout ce qu au delà donc ma
maîtrise à distance
je vais appeler liste m18 qui a fait à
partir de saic m18 et en fait la matrice
du coup c'est la même que tout à l'heure
donc j'ai pas besoin de la re définir on
va calculer le dos un programme de l'ape
les m18 et on va le représenter
donc là
on a eu le calcul à des distances j'ai
pas de message d'erreur mais il a bien
vérifié que que les inégalités et bien
été bien respecté j'ai réussi à vendre g
on voit que l'ag des résultats un petit
peu différente qu'il ya vraiment deux
gros séparation qui apparaît ici ce bien
visible là après j'ai deux heureux sous
des divisions passées si je découpe en
quatre et puis après on a des choses un
peu plus fine regardons ce que nous
donne le sec est ma pain qui de manière
de visualiser tout ça donc d'abord
l'objet séquence sec m18 puis l'arbre
donc arbres m18 donc la voyez un comme
toutes les séquences sur la même
longueur les variations ne sont que des
variations dans la composition des
séquences il n'y a pas du tout de
variations qui sont liées à des
distances ou des longues heures de
séquences qui sont différentes
et puis on commence à voir émerger des
différents groupes brillé dans les deux
gros séparation au on veut bien qu' il
n'y a quand même pas mal de bleu foncé
alors qu'en bas il ya quasiment pas de
bleu foncé ya parfois un petit peu de
vert si je regarde un peu les découpages
me suis un peu de grandes branches une
avec des gens qui restent pas vraiment
jaune donc ils doivent passer en fait
ils vont entrer dans les soins césaire
clair mais on voit assez pas ou assez
peu d étape après qu'ils sont une
station de traitement ou mis sous
traitement de certains ressortent du
soin là on a plutôt tout un groupe de
gens qui vont rester tout du long on
diagnostique qui vont pas rentrer dans
les soins du tout là on a des gens qui
vont entrer en soins ce que signifiait
le traitement de manière un peu tardive
l'épicier je regarde de ce côté là bas
on va avoir des gens qui vont atteindre
le contrôle virologique avec à peu près
d'eux un sous-groupe ici qui vont des
gens qui vont atteindre assez rapidement
et là un groupe de gens qui vont
atteindre un peu plus tardivement la
question du coup elle va quand même se
se pose est de se dire est ce que je
peux je peux est-ce que je prends trois
modalités quatre pénalités 5 modalités
ci modalités c'est toujours le problème
avec une classification choisir le
nombre de modalités et en fait il ya une
petite fonction qui est pas mal qui
s'appelle à 5 fruits qu'il apparaît de
de voir l'impact de ces différents choix
lorsqu'on lorsqu'on choisit deux trois
ou quatre modalités alors par contre
donc ce que je vous ce qui se passe
c'est que pour ça on a besoin d'avoir
installé une
une librairie graphique ça peut être
avisé qui s'installe pas forcément
facilement mais si vous allez sur le sur
la séance d'aujourd'hui d'accord donc là
un de la séance d'aujourd'hui oui vous
avez le lien vers le chapitre analyseur
trajectoire de soins et donc 6
regarde le chapitre sur notre deuxième
séquence imiter 18 premiers mois on vous
en parle ici donc il ya là il ya une
fonction intéressante qui est à ce point
secte chemise de l'extension white
leicester donc ytc la star c'est un
package développé par les auteurs de
traminer mais qui vient fournir des
fonctions additionnelles
là encore une fois pour ce paquet je
vous invite aussi à les voir le site web
du package parce qu'il ya un très très
bon mode d'emploi qui a été développé
par l'équipe parce que s'est développée
par une équipe de chercheurs suisses et
il vous faut pour ça
la librairie gr 6 si vous savez pas
installé vous avez ici le code qui vous
permet d'installer aircraft vise 1 pour
l'avoir à disposition
maintenant je reviens ici si vous aviez
un seul écrase vise 1 on peut du coup
chargé la librairie waited kloster que
vous devez aussi installer mais vous
pouvez installer un parent directement
par le bouton package ici j'ai rajouté
un quietly égal
ça permet de d'avoir un peu moins de
texte voyez vous avez ici un manuel
complet en français 1 qui existe et pour
rappel quand j'en parle des manuels
si vous savez pas où les trouver le plus
simple vous tapez dans google grand
c'est le répertoire des paquets de ger
bat vous tapez le nom d'un package si je
t'apprends whitey cluster j'arrive sur
la page cran du package like it cluster
d'une part j'ai un lien vers le site web
du package ici on peut trouver pas mal
d'informations complémentaires et vous
avez ici regardez un manuel et en plus
vous avez la chance pour les titres sur
le manuel est aussi disponible en
français et si vous avez tout un pdf qui
est un manuel de 34 pages qui vous qu'un
guide pratique pour la création de
typologie de trajectoire en sciences
sociales avec air par mathias suder donc
vraiment là je ce que je fais dans les
webinaires je vous donne en fait une
présentation de ce qu'on peut faire
bousiller un peu un aperçu est vraiment
le jour où vous êtes intéressé par ces
méthodes à aller vous auto formé à les
lire ces manuels on va vous expliquer en
détail ce que ce qui apporte les enjeux
théoriques méthodologiques et les
opérations pratiques qui sont vraiment
très bien fait que ce soit le manuel de
traminer ou le manuel de wight is the
stone donc je reviens ici donc je vais
charger la librairie waked cluster je
vais vous montrer du coup ce qu'on peut
faire avec
alors on peut faire un hard de séquences
avec has sec fri donc une fonction
fournis par webster il lui faut lui
passer un arbre un an plus d'un
programme qu'on a calculé lui donner les
données de séquences donc je vais faire
cette date à égal sec 18
l'objet séquences et il a aussi besoin
pour éviter dehors de leur calcul est
donc dit c'est la matrice est la matrice
de distance donc disent tu aimes 10 bits
et pour gagner important de calcul on
peut lui dire le nombre maximum de
classe à explorer donc la cnt store et
je vais dire 7 au maximum
on va lancer ce calcul et puis en fait
je vais récupérer les résultats donc
j'ai appelé c'est un objet que
j'appelais secte riz m18
donc en fait ce que ça fait alors ça
prend un petit peu de temps en fait ça
va prendre le temps lantana la prise de
distance et puis vous allez voir le
résultat une fois qu'on va être projeté
visuellement en espérant qu'il va
quelques élus sauf à ce qu'il attaque
les capulet il se passe j'ai
l'impression
r
un peu
alors ce que je
mais perçue diot compte parfois il ya un
petit souci la joie
et puis en général sur le live comme il
ya tout le logiciel de streaming
le pc est un petit peu moins réactif que
d'ordinaire je vais réouvrir studio
donc là
la veille il avait pas garder
l'environnement donc ce que je vais
faire je vais simplement exécuter tout
le code pour me remettre dans l'état où
j'en étais pour rien un exemple concret
quand vous avez un problème vous
redémarrez tout simplement est idiot
vous relancez le code depuis le début ça
prend parfois un petit peu de temps mais
au moins vous êtes tranquille si tout se
instantanément magie sur un peu
merveilleuse nous voilà on est dans la
vraie vie aussi de l'analyse statistique
là ça va encore on verrait la semaine
prochaine on va lancer quelques calculs
qui eux prennent carrément des heures
mais il aurait préparé en amont
donc pendant que
je vous rappelle donc l'idée whiting
kloster c'est un package complémentaire
à traminer qui fournit des outils pour
accompagner et faciliter finalement le
choix des trajectoires au revoir
quelques-uns aujourd'hui à bon droit
qu'il ya un bug qu'est ce que par son
nom avec des pelotes m18
ou est-ce que ça c'est à oui voyez
regardez j'ai dû faire une fausse manip
avec mes raccourcis clavier ou je règle
et q2 ceux ci avaient dû mettre un
certain caractère spécial on va faire la
suite pour voir si tout ce qui est le
plus correctement georgie stoop sa
graphique se met en place et j'exécute
cette partie n'a aussi jeu
art d une sauvegarde je peux toujours un
moment donné aussi sauvé mon
environnement de travail pour retrouver
cette étape là est plus simple quand
c'est en fait tout l'environnement
travaille on l'appelle tout simplement
point air data 100 mètres de nous alors
maintenant que j'ai créé l'objet c'est
cuit et me 10,8
je voulais voir
dans la console donc ses fruits et mme
en fait c'est pas très très visible
présenté comme ça on a plutôt intérêt à
le représenter de manière graphique qui
se fait avec la fonction complémentaire
donc secte riz à ses lectrices et celle
qui va calculer un arbre de séquences
pour la partie calcul est ensuite et
pour utiliser cette jolie display à
laquelle on va passer l'objet secs
fruits m18 et ici si vous n'aviez pas
installer la librairie avis on devrait
tout à l'heure vous auriez un message
d'erreur il se trouve que sur mon pc je
lé bien installé alors qui est un petit
peu particulier c'est que ça fait un
résultat qui s'affiche
voici le résultat qui aurait été créé
donc en fait c'est un peu atypique ça va
le présenter dans un autre graphique
oui l'idée parce que ça vous montre ses
jeux par 1 2
je je pars de mon objet à de longs donc
là vous avez l'ensemble d'accord des
séquences et puis il a montré ce qui se
passe lorsqu'on divise au fur à mesure
par défaut si je me trompe pas ils vous
présentent pas toutes à pitre séquence
mais uniquement les séquences les plus
communes
mais dans cette truie display ont
célébré dans l'aide de sectes oui
display il ya plein d'options qui sont
possibles ce qui va nous intéresser ici
ces deux spécifié on veut les tapis de
séquences et donc ça se fait avec type
égale 30e' donc en fait quand vous allez
sur
sipa en fait c'est le type de graphique
que l'on fait avec traminer en fait
qu'ils sont passés à l'objet cette
pelote donc ce type égal si ça permet
d'avoir du couple tous les tapis de
séquences et donc je vous refais le
graphique
voilà et donc
voyez donc là j'ai eu mon tapis de
séquences par défaut ça crée un fichier
temporaire
ainsi vous voyez là ça m'a créé un
fichier ton poids si je veux le
sauvegarder parce que là je vais
exécuter
je peux faire par elle-même et lui
donner du coup un nom de fichier donc là
ça serait le plus écrit m 18 ponts png
et en faisant ça l'image créée
ici elle est créée et du coup dans mon
répertoire travail donc je pourrai
récupérer ce graphique l'ain alors
voyons voir maintenant ce graphique et
comment ce combat là que vous avez c'est
le tapis de séquences global donc ça
c'est le tapis de séquences de
l'ensemble du fichier
il est pas très bien ordonné mais on
voit que c'est très mélangées maintenant
si on coupait au premier endroit alors
vous remontre notre notre dans le
programme ici ainsi je suis la première
coupe l'eau donc ça veut dire diviser en
deux classes sigi visant de clages
obtient deux groupes
et vous avez ici de petites séquences de
chacune de ces deux groupes donc
vous avez après celles ci ont redit vie
chacun encore en deux groupes l'accord
donc la 6 journée ils ont de gros vous
avez des petits contes et on voit bien
que ça commence à répartir en des choses
de plus en plus fines vous avez ici les
effectifs
par contre je pense qu'un tout petit
détail attendrait rajouter dans l'aide
on sait chaude of voilà si je prends ce
petit paramètres cela serait encore plus
face ça sera un graphique un petit peu
moins à ça sera un graphique un peu plus
facile à suivre
la graphique
peu différent mais oui là on voit bien
les étapes successives si je coupe en
trois ans quatre ans cinq alors si je
coupe en trois modalités 1 je vais avoir
du coup ce groupe là et ces deux groupes
là donc on voit qu'on a trois classes
une qui est jaune avec un petit peu de
vert clair qui traîne une quand même
très très dans les très rapidement dans
le bleu foncé et pink isa met du temps à
arriver dans bleu foncé si jamais je
divise en quatre groupes
donc si je pars en quatre classes cette
classe là elle va être divisé en deux
donc là c'est une case qui fait audible
à 1310 cet individu là on a une case 705
ci gisent en kata va faire une classe de
565 et niklas 240 celle ci aurait elle
est très très jaune avec un tout petit
peu de couleur et là on a une classe de
gens qui vont rester à ces pauvres
jeunes ou qui vont quand même rentré en
soins mais qui vont guère aller au delà
si je décide de me rajouter encore une
place dans l'analyse on de montain cinq
classes on voit que c'est ce groupe-ci
donc ce groupe si ce sont les gens qui
vont atteint la charge vers le contrôler
mais cela ils sont très rapides cela ils
sont plutôt lents ça va me distinguer
mêlant entre d un peu lent et des très
lent
si je divise encore en six classes et ce
groupe-là de 336 individus qui va être
divisé en un groupe de 295 assez
uniforme et un petit groupe de 41 qui
vont être des gens qui voyez vous
rentrez en soins vont démarrer un
traitement hills arrive en bleu foncé
mais ils vont mettre du temps à être en
bleu très foncée donc met du temps à
atteindre le contrôle biologique donc en
fait ce type de graphique vont permettre
comprendre ce qui se passe étape par
étape qui se passe quand on dit quand on
désire quand on décide de redit viser de
plus en plus en classe et donc ça
vous aider à choisir à quel endroit
faire votre retour de classe comme
souvent un des enjeux c'est de se dire
ah
est ce que je veux beaucoup beaucoup de
classe ou est-ce que j'en veux plus si
j'ai beaucoup de classe je vais garder
plus de détails mais j'ai encore plein
de petites cases donc pour les indices a
peut être qu'on coup j'ai du mal à
l'aise une information si j'ai pas assez
case je perds de l'information non c'est
toujours une question de priorité une
autre possibilité
là j'ai créé un objet secte fruits n 18
du coup si je veux pouvoir l'afficher
dans mon rapport et la mag la zone parce
que du coup là ça ne leur envoie pas
directement ça a créé le fichier image
on peut rajouter une image en marque
down pour ça j'ai regardé le matin en
cui cui flames savoir c'est quoi la
syntaxe pour mettre une image une image
c'est un point d'exclamation entre
crochets un nom alternatif que bam on
sait qu tri est entre parenthèses le
chemin de l'image est donc là mon image
s'appelle secte fruits m 18 points png
d'accord et en mettant ce qu au delà
dans mon fichier remarque donne ça
permettra d'intégrer mon image dans mon
rapport final lorsque j'essaie petit à
la toute fin
je vous présente sa rapidement pour vous
dire que ça existe un qu'il est possible
éventuellement amont d'explorer
différents indicateurs de qualité
donc vous avez ça c'est white leicester
et comme vous voulez dire vous avez le
manuel de la librairie white quelque
chose que je vous invite à lire en
détail ses 34 passes que ça va vous
expliquer les différents indicateurs
mais il ya il existe différents
indicateurs pour essayer d'évaluer la
qualité d'une partition et donc du coup
la question c'est est-ce que c'est nous
partitionner en trois ans quatre ans
cinq consisterait plus ou moins meilleur
et il ya une fonction éventuellement à
regarder qui la fonction ask se range
alors je vais être un objet je vais
appeler nc donc pas clust
waouh donc on lui passe un arbre un
dendre g
on lui passe une matrice de distance 18
vous voyez c'est pas
fier qu'à l'analyse de cinq ans puisque
c'est alors qu'on a un ton de regret
mais une matrice de distance qu'on peut
calculer ces indicateurs
donc ça peut aussi servir dans une c'est
une classification ascendante hiérarchie
sts qu'on réalisera à partir d'une assez
m
une analyse des correspondances
multiples alors par exemple je peux
faire c'est mary 2 nc
voilà ça fait beaucoup de temps je ne
mets plus tôt dans la console en ce sens
du facile alors ça regarde en fait sur
pas mal d'indicateurs quelle serait la
meilleure classification et là il va me
dire par défaut que sur ces différents
indicateurs la meilleure classification
serait 2,20 au 12 mai je crois que je
peux faire max points hank
voilà il me permet de voir d'autres
indicateurs donc encore une fois il ya
plein d'indicateurs différent je vais
pas pouvoir tous vous les présenter mais
retenez que du coup et on peut aussi les
représenter graphiquement
donc si vous avez vous hésité entre à
chercher d'autres éléments pour pour
choisir une ombre de classification vous
pouvez vraiment vous référer à au manuel
regarder tout le travail théorique sur
la silhouette moyenne assume et moyennes
pondérées hier de lire à ses différents
indicateurs et ces indicateurs la alors
ce qui se passe et que la meilleure
classification n'est pas forcément la
même pour chacun des indicateurs mais ça
peut vous donner une idée de nous couper
encore une fois je pense aussi que très
sincèrement le nombre idéal de classe il
se base pas uniquement sur sur un
indicateur statistique automatique parce
que c'est pas forcément c'est plus
intéressant est souvent il vaut mieux
avoir une un choix raisonné sur le
nombre de classes là pour la suite
moi ce qui m'intéresse d'avoir un nombre
limité classe pour résumer mon
information là si je si j'ai quatre
classes ça serait pas mal si j'ai cinq
ça va juste me redit viser ce groupe là
en deux sous groupes qui sont finalement
assez proches qui ont juste eu un petit
délai de temporalité est on si ça va me
faire sortir un groupe un petit peu
atypique donc à ce stade là pour la
suite moi je vais rester sur quatre
classes
mais peut-être que pour d'autres analyse
je serai peut-être partie sur cette
souris classe mais tout dépend de ce
qu'on va vouloir faire dans la suite des
éléments et c'est à avoir vraiment au
cas par cas si on dit une fois qu'on a
trouvé un nombre de classes ici je vais
vouloir garder que quatre classes
pour rappel pour couper un arbre nombre
de places on a jusqu'au cours la
fonction touch oui donc
l un le raccourci pour faire un nouveau
dunk un bon code vous avez ici le bouton
and you chuck et vous pouvez faire aussi
contrôler altit ça vous fait directement
à vous ça vous tapez la partie qui
entourent henjak donc pour découper en
cas de classe j'ai tout simplement
recours à quatre jolis arbres m18 et je
vais indiquer qu'à égale quatre le
nombre de places que je veux avoir et
sur résultats là je vais le stocker du
coup alors comme on est sur mon groupe m
18 ans donc j'ai partir dans l'argile 18
je vais faire une nouvelle
une nouvelle variable que j'appelais
type au ch pour classification
ascendante hiérarchique et je vais le
stocker qui va me permettre du coup de
garder la formation pour rappel on peut
aussi représenter le don programme un
jeu pour ça si vous voulez faire des
graphiques dando g et cryptage coloris
je vous renvoie au chapitre sur la
classification ascendante hiérarchique
vous avez tous les éléments pour ça
alors si vous allez lire le manuel de la
librairie wight is wight cycle store
dont je vous ai déjà parlé
matthias schoder explique qu'on peut
adresser plusieurs critiques aux
procédures hiérarchique comme la
classification assommante hiérarchique
en particulier le fait que la fusion de
deux groupes se fait à chaque fois en
maximisant un critère qui est local dans
le dans l'espace de la matrice de
distance et sans avoir une vue globale
il ya un autre algorithme qui s'appelle
pam pour partie schoening awards mais de
ips paix à m qui suit notre logique que
les algorithmes et hiérarchique et qui
vise obtenir une meilleure partition
d'un ensemble de données en un nombre
prédéfini groupe
et son avantage c'est qu'il cherche à
maximiser un critère global et pas
simplement un critère locale donc il va
essayer de maximiser à la répartition de
l'ensemble du nuage ou la matrice de
distance par contre cet algorithme là il
nécessite que le nombre de classes fois
connu à l'avance alors que lorsqu'on
faisait notre d'an dro g en fait les
regroupements se font étape par étape et
du coup on peut choisir ensuite si on
veut un concours un découpage en trois
classes 4 à 5 la cicas donc maintenant
que par la classification ascendante
hiérarchique on a décidé de couper en
cas de casse eh bien on va voir là ce
qu'on peut améliorer notre découpage
avec du coup l'algorithme partitioning
mais de hits
oui on peut du coup partir du coût de
l'extension white plaster fournit une
une fonction wck mais de id qui permet
de faire ça alors encore une fois je
montre juste les possibilités si jamais
vous vous dites ah mais moi sur mes
propres données j'ai intérêt à appliquer
ce type de méthodologie
je vous renvoie vraiment au manuel de
whitey plasters pour bien comprendre les
enjeux méthodologiques techniques et ils
trouvaient toutes les références
requises donc l'idée c'est qu'on va
utiliser donc la fonction wck mais de
ids du package ytc foster's qui a besoin
en entrée du matrix à distance c'est
notre disent tu aimes 18 à qui on va
indiquer le nombre de classes que l'on
veut donc nous on en veux tu être
et puis il est possible pour éviter de
recalculer un an gros g alors comme nous
l'avions déjà calculé de lui passer le
dans vos hommes qu'on avait calculé donc
initial clust qui est à 1 18
du coup il va partir de la
classification des programmes pour pour
gagner du temps dans le calcul du coût
de la delà de la méthode partie
mais loïc et puis du coup on veut
sauvegarder les résultats dans un objet
que j'appelais pam m18 si on regarde
l'objet pas même dix huit que l'on
obtient donc là en fait par défaut ça va
nous afficher un certain nombre
d'indicateurs qui sont des indicateurs
de qualité en fait de deux parties
sionisme est encore une fois pour ses
indicateurs
je vous invite à les regarder du côté de
du manuel pour avoir plus d'informations
si je reviens la structure de l'objet
qui met renvoyer m 18
donc ça contient un premier élément clé
clustering qui sont du coup mon
découpage en classe et puis un centre
d'information de c'est ici qu'ont été
calculé
donc moi ce que je veux récupérer c'est
ma classification est donc dans mon
objet large n 18
j'ai créé une nouvelle variable
cette fois ci qui la typo avec la proche
pam est donc ce que je veux récupérer du
de l'objet pam m18 c'est ce premier
élément qui s'appelle toy story et
maintenant
ça et si l'on comparé à 6 ont comparé
les deux classifications qu'on a obtenus
donc on va faire un tableau croisé on
peut le faire avec dit il se marie donc
j'ai chargé d'itis mari en mémoire qui
croyais est légal trop pour avoir
quelque chose moins verbeux et je vais
faire un bébé elle donc on va partir de
large et mme 18 sur lequel on va
appliquer tibet au cross un tableau
complet c'est ce qu'on veut c'est en
ligne va mettre nos petits pots ch et en
colonnes on va mettre notre type au pam
alors le nom des classes un pur moment
est un petit peu barbance dans l'ansé h
s'appelle une deux trois quatre
on n'est pas forcément très intéressant
anti popham elle s'appelle 6 23 85 410
on verra après sur à quoi ça correspond
ce qu'on voit c'est que ma la tipp le 6
types aux femmes c'est à peu près
équivalent aux tea pot 2 ch 1
ils sont ici la vanne 3 et l'a3
correspondent à peu près l'a330 il ya 85
aussi ainsi que la 410 et l'a4 est en
fait si on retire toutes ces cases là et
ben en fait on voit que les deux
typologies sont à peu près équivalente
et gros ça veut dire que grosso modo les
centres de classe 1 sont grosso modo les
mêmes on l'est où les îles sont voilà
ils sont vraiment équivalent et c'est
peut-être pour les individus qui sont
plutôt en bordure de classe que entre
les deux entre les deux on va avoir
quelque chose d'un petit peu différent
alors ce qu'on peut faire c'est regarder
un peu ce que donne un de typologie nous
pour rappel si vous retournez dans
chapitre d'analysé assurent les années
de séquences on va faire les tapis de
séquences alors de base faire un tapis
de séquences avec traminer c'est la
fonction sec et plates voyez le ym le
hic on a utilisé tout à l'heure un
majuscule deux types de graphiques
donc je vais lui passer mon objet sec m
10 mon objet de ces camps donc 5ème 18
et puis je vais dire que je vais et
groupe et part variable donc les larges
m18 doigt la typo on va commencer par
regarder petits pots ch alors là oui les
quatre groupes
si vous vous souvenez de l'upa de la
session qu'on avait fait un sur sur
l'analyse de séquences on avait vu une
petite astuce qui permettait d'améliorer
un petit peu les tapis de séquences
puisque quand on fait tapis de ces camps
sont là en fait les séquences à sont
présentés en fait dans l'ordre du
fichier par défaut et une petite
technique c'était de passer par la
fonction cmd scraire qu'on appliquait en
fait à notre matrice de distance et qui
permettait de trouver un ordre qui
permettait d' ordonner et finalement nos
séquences d'une manière un peu plus un
peu plus ordonnée vous allez voir la
différence donc je vous remets le code
qu'on avait vu à qu'explicite aidant
chapitre sur l'analyse de séquences et
on applique la fonction cmd scraire sur
notre matrice de distance existe deux
disques dont 18 kayak simple on veut
être sur une seule dimension c'est juste
pour avoir quelque chose qui va
permettre de redonner nos éléments et
cet ordre là je dors le sauvegarder dans
dans le tableau de large n 18
donc c'est un ordre selon sem d
en fait
mais on prenait tout notre matrice de
poing et dans cet espace là on allait
ordonner les gens sur un seul axe avec
le cun égal 1
ce qu'on obtient ainsi je vous montre à
quoi ressemble la reine 18 ordres cmd
voyez ces différentes valeurs donc les
ça va trier les points en leur donnant
une position sur un axe gauche droite
mais en utilisant du coup cette valeur
là pour trier le fichier sorte je
rajouter dans mon équipe lot avec sorte
vais en donnant cette valeur là donc je
vous le remet jours fun classique avant
d'être ici la version les yeux on voit
ces graphiques on a par défaut sans
avoir trié et maintenant je le fais la
version trier alors je vous met les deux
côte à côte ce centre je vous met ça
dans un petit choc à pare pour par
calculer l'heure puisque ça prend un
petit peu de temps voilà si je fais
ah je vous exécute le code donc là je
les ai quitte rapidement à cliquez sur
le bouton exécutés soit contrôle halde
c'est donc ça c'est sans le tri est là
avec le tri vous voyez la manière dont
s'est présenté manière un peu différente
mais le groupe iii c'est un peu inégal
et là en mettant ça eh ben on a une
sorte on voit bien que ça va trier
defacto entre ce qui est montré assez
vite en bleu foncé ce qu'ils vont être
plus de temps dans la catégorie l'une on
voit bien que tous ceux qui voyaient là
l'ailé on voit bien que tous ceux qui ne
sont pas du tout rentrer en ce sens
qu'ils sont restés jaunes sont vraiment
rien au nom c'est une technique qui
permet de trier les tapis de cinq ans et
des rendre un peu plus lisible
maintenant on peut faire aussi était
toute séquence
je vais vous rajouter maintenant ce
qu'on a avec notre autre type o un éclat
type au pam
donc si on regarde bien j'aurai exécute
le tout
donc
séquence qu'on avait avec la
classification à son dirar chic on a
grosso modo 4 groupes un groupe ici de
gens qui vont rentrer en soins assez
vite
initier un traitement il passe en bleu
foncé et avec une sous partie qui va
atteindre du coup là le niveau contrôler
plus ou moins vite mais c'est des gens
qu'il reste qu' il reste quasiment pas
en jaune y basque hui quasiment tous
assez vite dans bleu foncé certains vont
peut-être passer un peu de temps en
verre donc c'est des gens qui rentrent
en soins initie traitement après un ou
deux mois puis on voit est sous
traitement
on a le groupe 3 des gens qui vont
mettre du temps
donc soit qu'ils vont rentrer en soins
tardivement ce qui rentre en sont assez
vite mais qui met tout en oeuvre d'ici
le traitement donc c'est des gens qui
clament ad on a des rapides
là on va avoir des lans là on a ce bas
qui vont avoir un parcours on pourrait
dire da son plein c'est à dire qu'ils
commencent à rentrer en soins mais ils
vont pas initié le traitement voire ils
ressortent de soins pour certains un où
ils vont même initié le traitement mais
ressortir l'arrière donc c'est des gens
qui ont vraiment des parcours incomplet
et là vous avez une grosse partie qui ne
va même pas rentrer en soins ou alors
qu'il va faire juste un petit passage
épisodiques en soins si je regarde donc
à envoyer g grosso modo
si je reprends un les gens ont rejoint
les rapides et lents et ce qu'on ait
parcours inabouti si je regarde la
typologie que j'obtiens avec
l'algorithme pam
je retrouve après ces mêmes quatre
catégories 1
mais rapide mêlant les gens qui vont
avoir des démarches inabouti et puis
ceux qui vont avoir qui ont resté grosso
modo en dehors du soin alors c'est pas
tout à fait les mêmes
la question c'est lesquels on avoir d
être un peu plus pur un peu plus propre
en général la pam va permettre d'avoir
quelque chose d'un tout petit peu plus
propre
et puis éventuellement si vraiment vous
voulez regarder ça d'un peu plus près on
pourrait essayer de comparer la qualité
en fait de nos deux noms de nos de nos
deux classifications alors la qualité en
fait d'une partition à sylvain white
leicester propose une fonction double et
wc à classeur pour haïti donc si cette
fonction-là 1
l'idée c'est qu'on lui passe une matrice
distance donc la cedh east m18 et on lui
passe ensuite monde
c'est la typologie donc si je calcule a
qualité pour la typo chc accès de
fonctions là et je pourrai calculait
aussi la qualité du coup pour un petit
pot femme alors ski
intéressant c'est de regarder plutôt les
indicateurs en fait qui sont envoyées
par parlons de les stats je pourrais si
je rajoute un dollar stats g qc
indicateurs là et pour rendre les choses
un peu plus visible ce qu'on va faire si
je vais en faire un petit tableau
donc j'ai appelé tab donc j'ai fait un
petit bol poursuit un petit tableau
d'accord donc ça va voir les valeurs
pour pour la ch pour pam s'est même code
sauf que ici ces types aux femmes
j'affiche mon tableau une banque une
virgule un petit bol pour
tables donné l'âge obtient directement
imputables loire j'ai perdu en faisant
tout ça le nom des différents
indicateurs
en fait si je prends cet objet là je le
regarde on la console quand on voit que
c'est un vecteur nommé donc je peux
récupérer les noms des championnes
indicateurs en fait c'est juste le nom
de cet objet donc là
j'ai mon petit tableau d'accord et puis
si je vous présenter parce que je vais
être dans un rapport d'un peu plus on
peut utiliser éventuellement le package
la fonction câble dock twitter un long
câble ça permet de présenter c'est la
fonction un peu générique pour présenter
un tableau dans un rapport à magda sonné
pour en faire un tableau propre mais
vous avez aussi depuis quelques temps à
toute l'extension dit i am r of tribe
rôle la grammaire des tableaux qui est
la même équipe de leur studio qui
al'effet djidji pelote qu'est la
grammaire des graphiques et gîtes y est
notamment utilisé par par jet ismaily
donc c'est vrai oui en fait en général
se repose sur jetty pour transformer en
fait ils préparent le tableau mais après
celui qui va faire la présentation dans
un format html ou world s'est dit i donc
on peut citer la fonction jti du package
est dit il aussi
mais si je fais ça voyez j'ai
directement mon résultat sous forme d'un
petit tableau et puis dans le litige on
peut aussi dire qu'on veut formaté sous
forme de nombres donc je peux faire
appel à la fonction de jti formate sein
avancé fmt alors c'est tout est fonction
de formatage une colonne qui a donc jti
alors j'ai fait femme tn number pour de
formater dénombre je vais indiquer les
colonnes concernés c'est la deuxième et
la troisième et je vais indiquer que je
veux deux chiffres après la virgule et
voyez ça me permet d'afficher mon
tableau sous une forme simple alors par
défaut c'est que dit ti est très
américain qui utilise la virgule comme
séparateur de milliers si on veut on
peut modifier séparateur de milliers
avec la fonction cette marque et je
crois qu'on peut pour changer le
séparateur de décimales avec tess marque
donc si je fais ça je me dis que je veux
un espace vous séparez les milliers et
une virgule pour séparer les décimales
alors là ça va être comparé à nos deux
partitions la partition crh les
partitions pam donc sur une série
d'indicateurs alors vous avez tous ceux
là qui sont plus je vais pas rentrer
encore une fois ces indicateurs si ça
vous intéresse vous pouvez les regarder
dans le manuel et le mode d'emploi de
whitey cluster qui présente ces
différents indicateurs qui compliquait
sais que pour certains indicateurs la
meilleure partition c'est celle qui va
le minimiser dans d'autres cas c'est la
partition qui va le maximiser ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est que pour la plupart
de ces indicateurs la partition obtenu
avec l'algorithme femmes marchent un
petit peu mieux que la partition obtenu
avec la catégorie ch
mais encore une fois c'est seulement si
on a besoin d'indicateurs numérique pour
comparer nos deux partitions qui n'est
qu'une manière de faire du coup ce qu'on
va essayer de faire un on a vu on a
quatre groupes distincts
on les a vus ici un pour simplifier la
lecture je vais donc parler des rapides
ceux qui vont rentrer en soins très
rapidement des lances qui vont mettre du
temps pour entrer en forme et qui vont
finalement rentré en soin d or soins
pour ceux qui ne font finalement rentre
pas en soins et des inaboutie pour ceux
qui vont entamer une démarche soins mais
vont pas aller jusqu'au bout
là le nom je donne à mes catégorie c'est
bien moins qui fut une interprétation
sociologique des résultats obtenus à
partir description il a pas rien d'un
point de vue statistique qui va nous
permettre de trouver automatiquement les
bons noms à appliquer où on a ici
graphiques ont obtenu avec s'équipent
knox avantageuse graphique c'est que ça
permet de faire très rapidement le tapis
de séquences de nos différents éléments
mais si vous regardez bien
la catégorie représentée avec la même
hauteur alors que les rapides ils sont 3
194 l'élan sont 210 les uns les
inaboutie sont 167 et les hors soins
sont 546 en fait cette augmentation
graphique cela ne rend pas compte du
vrai poids relatif des différentes des
différentes catégories
c'est pour ça que ce qu'on va refaire on
va refaire un tapis de séquences qu'on
va leur créer avec gégé pelote pour
avoir un texte séquences plus propre et
plus pertinents
l'astuce pour faire un tapis de
séquences avec gégé pelote c'est à dire
en fait que ce tapis de séquencer
finalement représenté chacun division et
nine donc en fait on y j'ai la position
d'individus savoir son rang et donc
savoir montrer comment la recréer et on
va avoir finalement en x le mois et en
fait c'est ce qu'on appelle un type de
graphique et un s'appelle un racheteur
c'est à dire des directeurs qui sont
dessinés autour d'une position en x une
position on y est qu on va remplir avec
une couleur particulière pour ça il va
me falloir néanmoins gg pelote eux
attend d'avoir les des sous un format
loup 1 c'est-à-dire une observation par
point un mètre sur le graphique et non
pas un format large
or jusqu'à présent va travailler avec
des formats l'argent donc il va nous
falloir faire une version longue
mon
deux mots de mes données d'un format
long du deuxième 18
je vais déjà passé par faire c'était de
petites transformations
déjà on va créer une variable groupe qui
va être un peu plus propre
donc dans large 18
je fais un mieux tf1
je vais même pas m'embêter on va passer
par questionnaire pour aller plus vite
je fasse rco d'emma variable typo type
au pam en une variable qui fait plus de
qui va être fait un peu plus de sens
alors on se souviendra 1,85 seller
rapide 23 c'est l'élan 410 céline abouti
et si c'est leur fond donc ce que je
vais faire ici je vais prendre le adin
l'hiver ou brico ding qu'on a déjà vu
plusieurs fois qui fournit pas
cautionnaire donc j'ai pour mon objet
qui est large m18
je reconnais matip au pam je vais en
faire une des variables que j'appelais
groupe qui sera un facteur à la fin et
en terme de hre cottage on a donc dit
que si c'était l'erreur soins 23 l'élan
85 cd rapide et 400
et c'est dès inabouti j'ai du coup le
code 1 qu'yvette qui va être nécessaire
il est là
en fait il a transformé déjà en fait il
peut pas me citer des chiffres une
variable de type textuel avant
d'appliquer cet héros code et pouvoir du
coup la voirie si je clique sur donne ça
va me copier le code à l'endroit où j'en
ai besoin
et puis maintenant vers changé donc je
vais exécuter ce qu au delà
et puisque je cherchais ordonné quand
même mon mai mais catégorie parce que on
peut se dire quand même qu'il y a la
pire erreur soins à la meilleure qui
sont les rapides du point de vue de la
santé publique donc pour mes graphiques
ça serait intéressant les avoir quand
même dans un ordre qui fasse sens donc
là je vais partir sur liberos ordering
donc je suis dans l'objet large m18
ce qui m'intéresse est de recouper
groupe ça va à l'essai à un groupe c'est
juste que je mette les rapides puis
l'élan puis l'inévitable puis d or soit
on se permet d'ordonner dans un ordre
qui fait sens pour la présentation des
graphiques
je clique sur donne et là j'ai un
rayonnement sont donc j'ai refait une
variable de type facteurs alors on
aurait pu écrire tout ça de manière plus
rapide avec la fonction factor à vous le
verrez d'ailleurs supposer sur chaque
pays analysées mais mais si on est si on
est si on veut aussi on ne reçoit pas
tous les codes c'est facile de
réutiliser du coup les petits adeline
qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent
donc l'idée et cycle art j'ai mon
fichier et puis je vais refaire un
fichier long je vais pas tout à fait
transformé aucune question
on va repartir du fichier large n 18
pour en faire un fichier l'on aime 18
pour retravailler du coup avec pivote
longue même si on aurait pu aussi
repartir du 4g qu'tu rien à faire de la
fusion
donc si là je pars du coût de l'argent
18 jeux par de larges m18 et je vais
faire un pilote longueur d'accord donc
inverse ou de se faire pour mériter
votre rider ce que je vois dans l'aide
d'accord c'est que je vais dire quels
sont les colonnes on va qu'on va passer
en long nemtsov préfet et value ce tous
c'est à dire comment donc là je vais
indiquer ce que je veux qu'ils aient
actuellement large vous remonte à quoi
ressemble arjen 18,1 donc j'ai la
variabilité des variables f0 à m
18 no typo 1 ce qui m'intéresse c'est
que pour m 0 m18
au lieu d'avoir à une grande ligne g et
mettre les uns en dessous des autres
avec une variable qui va compter le nom
du mois est une variable qui va avoir le
statut
donc j'ai fait un pied
longueur donc ce que je veux faire
pivoter ses des variables de f0 à m
18 n'est une touffe donc le nom la
variable ça va être
je vais rentrer le moins et value ce
choo avait du coup le caire states on va
faire ça et je vais regarder qu'est ce
que j'obtiens à quoi ressemble mon long
m18 vous voyez loin de 18 qui contient
lead in ancien patient la typo ca h à ti
popham l'ordre cmd qu'on avait créé il
ya maintenant une variable membres yves
om 0 et même de m3 et kirsten
si je
haarde ici un signe
textuel que j'ai pour manque alors
l'idée c'est que du coup on a le statut
là il en dtc dont je peux pour faire mon
graphique un jeu par du coup de mes
données longue donc gg pelote l'on aime
ensuite je vais jouer sur mes os donc en
x j'avais représenté le mois à la y
qu'on n'a pas encore fait il manque le y
d'alors l'astuce d'accord c'est qu'on va
représenter à les individus donc pour
les individus en fer forgé tri en
fonction de hordes cmv mais ce qu'il
faudrait c'est un deux trois qui
atteignent plutôt à un rang dans la dans
la position
donc si je reviens dans large et 1 18
ce que je peux faire ouh là je suis à
nîmes par individu je vais créer une
le paria bhl je vais trier large dont
j'espère amyot t2 ça marche je fais 1
mio tate
je vais donc ma position 1 l'âge et lord
cm d une fable ordre cmdc une variable
qui contient une valeur 10 ennemis 12,1
de moins 3 ce que j'aimerais c'est juste
avant toute chose c'est jeu mais même
dans l'ordre et 1 2 3 4 5 pour ça qu'on
appelle à un rang vous fait avec point
qu un qu'on a déjà vu vous devez faire
en une nouvelle map j'appelais rang cmdt
des galas
waouh h deux ordres
cmd un donc ça veut dire le premier le
deuxième le troisième ce qui se passe
c'est que s'il ya deux individus qui
sont la même position par défaut on leur
met la même valeur qui est moyenne is et
donc je vais modifier plutôt option ties
méthode first 1 pour caen pour qu'ils
soient séparés sont graphiques donc ties
méthode égale firth pour être sûr que
deux individus qui auraient la même
valeur deux ordres cmd et quand même
malgré tout 1 rend différent donc
maintenant quand j'avais fait mon pied
votre longueur gma variable transcend et
qui est présent dans l'ombre m18 et
voyez alors c'est une vraie
ap qu'il va falloir 2 3 4 5 mais qu'elle
a même un même individu aura la même
valeur de rang cnd et du coup
j'utilisais rance md pour pour dire
c'est la position de l'individu sur
l'axé y dans mon tapis de séquences et
enfin je la couleur va être déterminé
par ma variable caire des tos et on va
faire un géant home break tu es bien sûr
bien quelque chose
ce que c'est pas j'aimerais que ces
jeunes pasteurs up
donc voilà
graphique que l'on obtient comme vous
pouvez voir il ya quelques petits
problèmes
d'accord la première chose à j'ai bien
hâte à pitre séquence voyez le mois qui
pour le moment est il vrai textuel gm
faisait roem 1m 10ème 11ème 12 puis
après je reviens m2 a été trié manières
affables éthiques
donc j'ai intérêt à retravailler ma
variable mois alors ce que je veux dans
ce cas là c'est récupéré en fait quelque
chose je continue donc il faudrait que
je retire le m pour avoir juste 0 ou 18
je crois pas qu'on peut faire
directement avec pivote longueur et
comme je ne sais pas je vérifie s'ils
n'aiment ce précieux qu'est ce que ça
permet de retirer un préfixe voilà
justiz nm ce préfixe a priori un donc si
je fais même ce préfixe quelque chose
qu'on va retirer du nom donc si je
n'aime ce préfixe égal mm je regarde
longue m18 voyez maintenant d'avariés le
mois contient 0 1 2 3 4
ça m'a retiré mon prix fixe qui s'était
mis le m
par contre pour moment où je vois que
c'est en numérique
donc j'ai peut-être faire un petit peu
nettoyage en disant que l'on aime 18
morts
je vais dire que c'est du coup un nom -
est comme ça serait un nombre ça serait
correctement triés sur mon tableau est
là c'est bon
j'ai bien les mois de mois en mois qui
sont présentés entre 0 et 18 maintenant
j'aimerais retrouver mes codes couleurs
qu'on avait depuis tout à l'heure donc
je vais rajouter plus qui est 6ème
viridis pour retrouver les mêmes codes
couleurs qu'on a utilisées jusqu'à
présent
alors il faut que je précise mais il dit
discrète va relier ce plight continued
kerrand parce que ce qui est fait des
release par défaut on voit une échelle
continue or là je passe un statut donc
s'utiliser le discrète il faut que je
passe du coup l'option discrète et
gerald chaud dans mon ski au fil veridis
et on y est presque
il reste quelques petits soucis alors
mon kèr stade jos il est géré de manière
textuelle d'accord et donc du coup pas
forcément dans c'est pas forcément d'en
bas d'en dans l'ordre des différents
statuts qu'on a dit laurianne langue m18
kirstetter en fait j'ai bien mais la
belle et mes valeurs ici donc je
pourrais peut-être tout simplement dire
que je fais une variable vecteur de mon
kirstetter donc f pour facteur qui va
être un tout factor de l'ong m18
kirstetter comme jeu
facteur du package label d'appliquer un
recteur labellisé ça va me faire un va
me faire du coup un facteur qui est dans
l'ordre un des étiquettes
donc ça sera des cts donc si je fais ça
et que je dis j'utilise ma nouvelle
variable caire tsf à la place alors deux
choses
j'ai bien le bon ordre mais les couleurs
sont pas dans le bon sens donc ici il
faut que j'indique que change la
direction - 20 comme tout à leurs voeux
le jaune pour diagnostiquer mais pas
suivi pour être cohérent avant la même
échelle le graphique tout du long
et puis je vais juste pour faciliter
toutes ces lectures déplacer à la
légende en bas donc les djeunes point
position égale bottom genre
sur sur la légende tout à l'heure on
avance
plutôt bien sur le graphique qu'on va
obtenir mais il ya encore que
désajustement ce que j'aimerais du coup
ces voix mais mais mais différents
groupes
maintenant j'ai rajouté un sas est donc
je vais rajouter un facettes grid pour
séparer mais quatre classes c'était le
but de point de départ
donc les classes et la variable et donc
je vais dire facettes grid ou rose
pardon il pas loupé
donc j'ai indiqué que je veux faire un
fighting sommet groupe
alors voyez j'ai bien récupéré
le graphique pour mener 4-1 pour mes
quatre catégories mais il ya un petit
problème parce que - y étaient calqués
sur l'ensemble du fichier et du coup bah
là j'ai dit petit une partie qu'ils ont
une partie gang
l'astuce est d'en face est on va déjà
indiqué que les et les échellons pouvoir
varier avec sky freespace free jazz
indique tubize échelle peut le parier de
l'un à l'autre
c'est un peu mieux parce que du coup les
minimum et maximum de chacune des
échelles sont mises à jour mais j'ai des
trous par endroits 1 parce que il ya des
fois ben ça se suit pas d'une séquence à
l'autre et c'est parce que si je regarde
aujourd'hui ma variable rend donc si je
regarde l'on aime 18 saint laurent c'est
une variable qui est numérique puisque
je vais faire je vais la transformer en
une variable le facteur alors comme
c'est numérique les facteurs - dans le
même ordre mais l'astuce c'est que du
coup ça deviendra un y une variable
discrète qui représentait en y et le ska
frisbees free va avoir pour effet de
supprimer les valeurs d'un observé à
chaque niveau vous montrent l'astuce
et voyez là on a un vrai gain par contre
il va y avoir une grosse partie de
nettoyage des axes alors voir ex ps ju
sage et bien mais quatre partis qui sont
vraiment cohérente
je vais peut-être augmenter un peu la
taille du graphique pour que ce soit
plus facile à voir donc je vais faire
houston 111 figure je vais faire 8,8 en
taille par exemple et on va
amélioration du graphique avant de
s'arrêter là pour cette semaine donc ce
qu'on va faire on va redessiner
ici l'accent bas on va redessiner lax on
va supprimer les étiquettes sur l'exe 6
et puis on va effacer on va remettre
aussi des choses sur deux lignes par
contre il était un peu trop maintenant
mon graphique
donc j'ai dit l'an passé en 6 à 6 alors
pour simplifier c'est un peu la lecture
on va te virer une partie des tic est
donc labs x dégâts rôle y égale nos fils
égal
non ça ça va avoir pour effet de retirer
un pas mal des tic est maintenant je
vais retravailler
mon axe d y d'accord donc ça c'est 15
qu'elle y qui est discret et squid parce
que j'ai transformée en facteur c'était
astuces justement pour que tous
affichent bien avec le ska fruits de ce
fruit est simplement gfr la berd et au
lieu de donner comment les transformer
j'ai fait un nul
normalement si je me trompe pas ça
devrait bien tout effacer donc là on a
effacé les les labels à ce niveau là je
vais aussi alors le thème ressassement
plus tôt à la fin d'ailleurs on veut
aussi en profiter pour partir sur un
thème graphique plus j'ai je fais
vraiment m minimum
moralement ça ferait quelques dessins en
moins sur certaines éléments de légende
[Musique]
dans le thème
je vais revoir aussi mon accès fixe
alors on va faire deux choses la saisie
d'une part on va supprimer
oui le de ville en fait c'est parce que
l'accusé qui s'étend au delà du zéro et
du et du 18
parce que par défaut il ya une expansion
des axes pour être sûr que tous les
ponts soient bien représentés ces
paramètres
expand est ce qu'on peut faire avec ce
paramètre là donc si je vais faire la x1
c'est une variable continue puisque
c'est un numéro des mois si je regarde
ce qu'est x continue je vais vous
montrer l'aide de ce qu'elle x continuer
j'ai paramètres expense ici on regarde
l'aide du paramètre xpand ça nous dit
opposé jeunes ce qu'est un facteur waouh
expanding c'est à dire on nous on tourne
on nous un peu de un peu de marge
et en général il fait par défaut c'est
que ça ça par défaut en fait que sais-je
époque qui rajoute 5% de part et d'autre
et rajoute 0,6 pour les variables
discrète
quoi qu'il en soit ce que l'on doit
indiquer à xpand vous fait appel à aix
expansion et on a dit est ce que on
multiplie par un terreau d'une valeur et
où on additionne une certaine valeur
c'est ce qu'on rajoute deux pas de part
et d'autre donc là ce qu'on va dire
c'est que expand donc on fait appel à
expand shon et on indique 0 0 ne surtout
pas étendre si je fais ça voyez
maintenant mon graphique ça colle un
skin de la place parce qu'il ya plus
l'expansion autour du graphique
maintenant ce que je vais indiquer où
est ce que je veux un mythique est sur
mon graphique 1 mebrek ce donc là comme
c'est du temps je vais de 0 à 18
j'aimerais les 606 donc 06 12 18 18 ces
trois fois 6 d'où ces deux fois ci donc
je peux dire c'est 0 à nice
donc c'est
2.3 ça veut dire 0 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 si je
fais x 6 ça veut dire zéro x 6 0 1 x 6 6
2 x 6 12 3 6 10 8
et donc là un g20 dit directement 06 12
18 ans c'est quand même plus plus
efficace et je vais même aller un petit
peu plus loin au lieu d'afficher 0,6 g h
et m
donc je vais faire la balance donc là je
vais indiquer les étiquettes que je veux
donc je vais prendre la fonction
passeuse héros qui paye du texte et je
veux connu le texte m
aux valeurs 0,3 fois ci donc pour
comprendre 0 3 x 6 c'est le vecteur 06
12 18 et passe 0
m 03/06 ça nous renvoie du coup un
vecteur de textes f0 n 6 et 12 n 18 est
donc sur mon graphique il obtient du
coup ceux ci enfin il reste un dernier
élément qui décident d'améliorer la
légende donc là pour donner des
paramètres sur les gens ni fois appelé
de manière générale à fonction guide qui
est la fonction qui permet de donner des
éléments sur les légendes puis syndicats
les gens de quel esthétique là c'est
pour la légende s'il est là il faut
maintenant appeler la fonction guide
legends qui va permettre de définir la
halle des objets de légende pour guide
et là normalement je crois qu'on peut si
je
l euro je fais une colle égale un nom
selon m dire je veux que la légende pour
films soient fichés sur une seule
colonne et en faisant ça voyez ça se
mêlait au dessus de l'autre et je le
tiens quelque chose qui est lisible
je peux peut-être essayer sur deux
colonnes oui deux colonnes ça tient vous
voyez guide les jams et d'en appeler
d'un guide permet du coup de
personnaliser la légende donc là si vous
regardez bien ce qu'on a c'est bien un
papier qui représente un tapis de
séquences mais avec chacune des classes
qui sont on voit bien tout de suite que
la classe hors soins et beaucoup plus
grosse claque assénée beauty et qui a
moins de l'anc il n'ya de rapides donc
ça vous donne la hauteur ici de sources
graphiques had de chacun des blocs
correspond bien au nombre d'observations
et si vous aussi vous allez sur la page
chapitre sur un analyseur vous verrez
aussi de trop petites astuces pour
ajouter le nombre des effectifs
directement dans les étiquettes qui sont
ici
quoi qu'il en soit il est déjà 19 heures
ça fait deux heures c'est un peu long
quand même pour une vidéo donc ce que je
vous propose c'est qu'on s'arrête là
pour ce soir
la semaine prochaine
bordera du coup comment exploiter la
classification que l'on vient de faire
pour regarder les facteurs associés donc
on abordera notamment la régression
logistique multi nauviale on n'avait pas
encore eu l'occasion de le faire d'ici
là à portez vous bien et je vous dis du
coup à la semaine prochaine merci pour
tous et à très bientôt